(chill electronic music)
- Are these the new iPhones
that are going to be announced?
I don't know.
No, clearly, they are not.
These are just some fake dummy phones.
They're little prototypes.
You've probably seen a bunch of people
with these on YouTube already.
My friend Faruque let me borrow these.
He got them from somewhere,
I don't even know where.
Either way, we've got them
here for some size comparisons.
What we potentially could
have in store, in our hands,
very, very shortly.
Let's just jump into some of the rumors.
First of all, the biggest rumor is
what is this new phone going to be called?
There's three phones that
the rumors are saying
will be announced.
First up is the iPhone 10S MAX,
so instead the plus, they're
now replacing the plus with max
and again, everything I'm
saying is complete rumors.
I know nothing at all.
Everything that I'm saying
I have read somewhere on the internet.
6.5-inch OLED, edge-to-edge
stainless steel around the edges
glass back, and the iPhone 10S,
which would probably
be about the same size
as the previous version of the iPhone 10,
this one would be a 5.8-inch OLED.
I feel like the prices probably
would be sort of similar.
I think this one, I would assume,
would range from $800 to $900,
and a bunch of people were speculating
that the iPhone 10S MAX
would be anywhere from $900
to $1,000 to $1,100,
it really all depends.
They'll probably be
various different sizes.
There's also been rumors
that there's going to be
a 512 gigabyte model.
I don't even think that
I've filled up my 256 yet.
It's also been speculated that
there will be dual SIM cards,
which is kind of exciting
if you do travel abroad,
you won't have to keep switching SIM cards
when you're traveling internationally,
and it has been kind of cool
because when I do travel,
I have other phones
that do dual SIM cards,
and it's kind of incredible
'cause it just switches,
you don't have to worry about it.
Then that brings us to, not the
real phone but an iPhone 10R
so essentially that would be
kind of like the iPhone 9.
You guys remember last year
the iPhone 8 came out first,
and then a month later,
the iPhone 10 came out.
So, I feel like this is sort
of the upgrade to the 8.
It'll be a little bit less expensive.
It'll still have a huge screen,
full edge-to-edge display.
But it won't be OLED,
it'll probably be LCD.
These are all rumors, I read
it on the internet, who knows.
Could be fake news, could
be real news, who knows?
Because the iPhone 10R
will be less expensive,
it probably will have
aluminum around the edges.
It'll come in various colors,
gray, white, blue, red.
I'm hoping for a pink.
Probably a black, potentially an orange,
and because the price point will be lower,
there may not be 3D touch.
Probably won't have dual SIM cards,
and it definitely probably won't have
a headphone jack either.
Another thing people were
saying is that the new phones
may ship with a USBC to a lightning cable,
whereas previous, they would
be USBA to the lightning cables
so I would be pretty
excited about that because
I feel like I'm always looking
for a USBC to lightning,
and I can never find them.
One of the things that I've
been hoping for a while
that the iPhone would switch to is USBC.
I doubt it'll happen.
Especially people were
speculating they're just
shipping USBC to lightning,
so the likelihood of
that really happening is
not very likely.
So the newer phones will
probably come in three colors:
silver, space gray, and a rose gold,
which I am so excited about.
There's also been rumors
that there's going to be a
shiny, rose gold Series 4 watch.
If I have to wait in
line, I'll wait in line.
If I have to sleep outside,
I'll sleep outside.
I will do what I have to,
unless it's one of those things
like the original, when the
watch fist was announced,
that it was like extremely
expensive, it was like $24,000
for the gold watch or something.
Then maybe I might skip it.
If it's a realistic price, then yeah,
I'd sleep outside for it.
Of course all of the normal things
that you would expect in a new phone:
improved battery, faster modem speeds,
hopefully faster wireless charging,
because right now the wireless
charging is pretty slow,
so if that is actually a fast charge,
I'll be super excited because
I love wireless charging.
I hate having to carry cables around,
but I do like having
various docking stations.
And speaking of wireless charging,
do we even need to bring up,
I don't even remember what it's called,
power mats, the air mats.
No, the power mat was intentional.
You can run on the mat, oh
my god, that was so much fun,
with the track and field
game, oh, so great.
Back on track, the air power,
if that's not released at some
point I'm gonna lose my mind.
Speaking of air power, because
we're talking about air power
the air pods would need
to have a new pace,
so they may be announcing a new case,
or entirely new set of air pods,
which could potentially
have a Siri built in.
- [Siri Voiceover] Senior
buys the Beverly Hilton,
about 3.5 miles to bear east
- Oh.
- [Siri Voiceover] On Wilshire
Boulevard and Beverly Hills,
which averages four stars.
- You're not safe in my house
if you say the trigger words
for any smart home thing.
Not sure where I left off.
New air pods, air power, three
new iPhones, new Apple Watch.
Let's take a look at some of the rumors
because I haven't really got
a chance to do much research
on the Apple Watch yet.
So here on MacRumors,
which is my favorite place
to go for Mac rumors,
like we said before, the
2018 lineup is right here.
These are again the dummy models.
So you've got your iPhone 10S
MAX, iPhone 10R, and the 10S.
Obviously the newer versions
have the dual camera,
it should be 12 megapixels.
Here's some glass panels for 2018 models.
So you can see the different sizes.
And here's the 6.1-inch dummy
models in red, blue and white.
Three color possibilities.
One of the things that a
lot of the dummy models
do get wrong are the colors,
so I feel like that blue
is a little bit too dark.
I don't think Apple would
do a dark blue like that.
Here we are: Apple Watch Series 4.
This is super exciting.
I use my Apple Watch every single day.
There's been days where I've forgot,
and I've left it on its
charger and left the house,
and I just have sort
of this panic feeling,
because I'm so used to having it.
And a lot of times I do
keep my phone in my purse
or in my pocket or my backpack,
now especially because
I'm riding my bike a lot,
I rely a lot on this for Apple maps.
If I have a place in my GPS,
I can just look at this,
it tells me where to go.
This is the rose gold
that I was talking about.
This is one of the leaked images.
And it's a much more
shiny, kind of, color,
so this could be sort of
like a stainless steel,
with a rose gold plating or a copper,
they could be calling
it copper, I'm not sure.
Here's Series 3, and here's the Series 4,
so there's definitely a way bigger screen.
I do like it has the rounded edges.
I guess you don't really notice
that this doesn't have
a round-edge display
because it's usually a
black background anyway,
but I do like that that
is a larger screen.
Longer battery life
if enabled through a
higher-capacity battery.
Improved health monitoring.
I use this anytime I'm on a hike.
It's interesting because I
was at the doctor's one day
and I had to get a shot.
I don't do well with needles.
I think I'm dramatic, my
sister knows I'm dramatic,
my sister was with me, and I
started feeling a lit bit dizzy
and she kind of looked
at me a little strange,
and I was like, I don't
think I feel so good.
I looked at my watch, my
heart rate was, like, 42,
and I just sort of slumped.
It was one of those things
where I had the health data
on my wrist to show me that yes,
I was actually not feeling well,
and I should probably make
sure I was sitting down.
It was cool because,
not that I passed out,
but that I had that data
right in front of me
just to know that what I was feeling
wasn't just me being dramatic,
it was actually something that
I should pay attention to.
There's been so many health stories
of people who are having heart attacks,
and their Apple Watch saved their life.
These are Apple Watch upgrades:
EKG designed to detect
electrical changes in skin
caused by rhythm of the heartbeat.
It can determine if there
are any irregularities,
including hardware into the band,
including batteries, oh interesting.
So what that means is if
they have filed these patents
then there can be accessories
for your Apple Watch,
so there could be increased
heart rate sensors,
there could be something that
tests your glucose levels,
using sensors.
There are so many possibilities
if that's the case,
which I feel like it's
only a natural progression.
Another thing that they do
announce are new Apple watchbands
well, I would be excited to see that.
One thing that I am hoping
is that there are a
little bit more, I guess,
higher-end fashion watch bands.
There's so many third-party ones,
but one of the things that I don't like
about the third-party ones
is they don't always fit perfectly.
I feel like when Apple
does it, it fits perfectly.
It's a quality product, and
I don't have to question
whether or not it's
gonna work with my watch.
So that's something that I'm hoping for,
if they do have a rose gold,
or if there's, like, a
chain link one, or I dunno,
I'm not really sure what
I'm thinking that I want.
That's one of the things
that Apple likes to do.
They like to make the things
that you don't even know that you need.
So, thanks, Apple.
One thing that I do like is
that it looks like there's just
a very small red ring around the crown.
I know I wasn't a fan of the red,
but honestly I never really see it,
so it didn't bother me that much.
Now that I'm looking at
it, I like this way better.
So back to what we can expect:
air power, like I said,
this needs to happen.
I mean, this was supposed
to be out in 2018.
I guess 2018 isn't over, but
it sure feels like it is.
And here's our air pods.
We've got the old and got the new,
and as you can see that
little light right there
is lit up to show you that it's charging.
I can't wait to be able to
charge everything all at once
and just be done with it.
Software updates, new version
of iOS, MacOS, watchOS, tvOS
those have all been in beta,
so I don't really feel like...
Well, I haven't upgraded to
Mojave because I usually wait
because I don't wanna have to worry
is Final Cut going to act up?
Usually it doesn't,
but there have been some
very small instances,
so I usually wait several months
until after the OS is out.
I can deal with beta on my phone,
but I can't deal with beta on the Mac.
Possibilities for September
and October, iPad Pro,
Mac mini, oh, tell me more.
Low-cost MacBook Air.
12-inch MacBook, iMacs.
Following the debut of the
new phones and Apple Watch,
September 12, we're expecting
Apple to hold pre-orders
on Friday, September 14.
If Apple sticks to pre-order
times from the past year,
we can expect orders to be
starting at 12:01 a.m. Pacific.
Here they're saying if the
pre-orders happen on the 14th,
then the official launch
would be on September 21.
So, what does this mean?
I don't know.
Well, that's pretty much all
I have for you guys today.
But I will be at the event,
so be sure to follow me everywhere
on social media @ijustine
Twitter, Instagram,
YouTube, Facebook, wherever.
I'll be doing some live
streams, stay tuned.
But that's it.
I have to go edit this video,
pack and head to Cupertino.
I just went through this whole video
and now I'm thinking about how crazy it is
because when I was younger,
this was literally my dream.
My dream was to, well,
number one my dream was
to go and work at Apple,
but I never really realized
that there would be something
else that I could do
and sort of cover Apple Tech.
I dunno, I was a child, I had no idea.
Again, I mean, the internet, and you guys,
have made my small
childhood dreams come true.
So I just honestly, I
can't thank you enough,
and I look forward to giving
you guys some coverage
and if there's anything else
that you would like to know,
if you have any questions,
leave those in the comments below.
Everybody here is
usually super supportive,
and I love hearing from you guys,
so thanks for being an
incredible community, I love you.
Hashtag, IJ...
I don't, what's my hashtag?
Do I have a hashtag?
Team IJ?
It used to be IJ Army,
should we stick with that?
I think we'll stick with that, peace out.
There's a new Guayaje flavor.
It's sparkling blackberry mint.
Color me freaking impressed.
I'll see you guys in Cupertino.
(chill electronic music)